j'ai rencontré son excellence le
gouverneur général et il a accepté ma
demande de résoudre le parlement
après dix ans de stephen harper à trois
ils veulent tourner la page
vous savez qu'il est temps de changer de
se donner un nouveau gouvernement
en appuyant le bloc on faire la route
aux conservateurs les frontières est
prêt ce n'est pas le moment de jouer
avec nos économies c'est le moment de
garder le cap
je suis réseau à à réparer les dommages
causés par les déficits modeste serait
trop les trois premières années
les tribunaux ont statué comme vous
venez de le dire est qu'on aime ça qu'on
aime pas ça je ne commente jamais voté
pour les verts
voter pour vous
et surtout votre retraite pour rien
seulement tu pas venu pour perdre santé
donnez nous le mandat d'aller faire le
ménage à trois
nous sommes le parti de responsabilité
financière nous sommes le parti de la
sécurité et de la prospérité
le gouvernement harper a passé sa date
d'expiration
il est temps de le remplacer par un
meilleur gouvernement